hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast visualizing and tracking
extracellular vesicles delivery and RNA
translation by dr. Charles Lai hi I'm
dr. Chad Schwartz senior application
scientist at Beckman Coulter and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
webinar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by Beckman Coulter bakwin
Coulter is a leader in centrifugation
and flow cytometry and has long been an
innovator in particle characterization
lab automation and genomics that can
culture products are used at the
forefront of important areas of
investigation and discovery for more
information please visit Beckman Coulter
comm we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
at the lower left of the presentation
window we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can you can enlarge a
slide window by clicking on the icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problems to the
green Q&A button I would now like to
introduce today's speaker dr. Charles
Lai dr. Lai received his Bachelors of
Science in 2003 and PhD 2010 from the
University of British Columbia Canada
where he studied the role of gap
junctions and it's analogs connections
and glioma under the profet under the
guidance of Professor Christian Nelson
in 2010 he joined professors Andrew
brakefield and Baucus tennis
laboratories in Massachusetts General
Hospital and Harvard Medical School as a
postdoctoral fellow fellow and later in
2014 as an instructor to expand his
research horizon and cell-to-cell
communication centering on extracellular
vesicle mediated communication between
glioma and glioma stromal cells he
developed one of the first non invasive
methods to monitor EVs and cargo and
vitro and in vivo in 2015 dr. Lai joined
National Chinua university as an
insistent professor of the Institute for
biomedical engineering
I am pleased to now turn it over to dr.
Charles Lai for his present
hi everyone founders Charles on to
prepare for the client reduction as well
as technical through fourth indication
feel me to share all work with you today
so again this is my title for today
which is visualization in fact an x-ray
o'leary vesicle delivery and RNA
translation is in multiplex reporters
so as icebreaker so this would be my
first light most of the work actually
have been done in Boston and as you can
see we have one of the toughest storm
this year that there's no pencil part
that is almost installer and some
individual any case again the work had
been done at Harvard Medical School as
you can see on the left this is really
for the crowd and also a master in the
hospital under the guidance of dr. with
Sandra HBO as well as office to news now
after the first winter if aid for chance
that recently moved to National
University which into Taiwan to begin my
assistant professorship and as you can
see is a very vibrant campus with lots
of young students as well as nice
scenery colleges right by the mountain
not only yeah we actually have a nuclear
reactor as you can see on the top right
of the picture right here so it's really
kind of unique and we have a very strong
team of professors currently working on
biomedical research which I'll discuss
briefly towards the end of this talk you
know to define our talk which is on
extra fellow vesicles since I pretty
much grew up in Canada
so our useful from a radio station from
Canada which is Canadian broadcast
company CBC radio and they have it cold
for their program called the final cafe
and the pool is such that we may not be
big but we are small I thought this book
describes extra solid I spoke quite well
here honey but they actually do a lot of
things so let's head into what our
extracellular vesicles so as you can see
on the left right here here's an image
of the cells releasing little box which
later people realize our extrasolar
vesicles and on the right as you can see
right here are Qian pictures showing you
extra Sullivan's field exhibit
the double membrane structure and there
are various fight for populations of
extracellular signals which will use the
word eg in general that the smaller find
that people categorize the mass are
exosomes they have a diameter ranging
from 40 to 100 nanometers coming up are
the micro vesicles which the build
consensus are ranging from 100 to 1000
nanometer diameter and also the atopic
blast we're dying cells as you release
them they can be as big as up to 4000
nanometers in diameter not only that the
VC was group recently or in a couple
years that been finding the test result
actually really really big vesicles that
in outer term as aquas ohms
they're also fear grow for cell to cell
communication by the vesicles so how do
they exactly communicate with one
another by using this ability
so in essence as a schematic diagram to
show you on the left right here we have
the donor cells so what happened is that
these donor cells can actually release
vesicle Dirac through fusion of the
microphysical body to release a little
vesicle which will be different exosomes
or the budding of the vesicles from the
membrane then later scientists had to
realize that they carry a lot of cargo
including her things DNA as well as RNA
and when these vesicles reaches they're
receiving cells they can actually upload
these files and thereby affecting the
recipient cells either through direct 13
or like interceptor interaction or more
so in recent findings they found that
the vesicles actually rely on micro RNA
to manipulate the gene expression so how
about vesicles relevance to diseases so
a lot of people have been finding that
vesicle I'll be a very tiny as far as
you can see right here they have a lot
of relevance to many of has a disease
including cancer neurological disease
such as a dimer that has been actively
researched on and as well as prisoners
and also heart disease that people found
that cardiovascular disease tend to
release a lot of vesicles
as well as open immune disease that's
what people are looking for anything
and also people have found a desk first
thing actually fine infection by the
resources but I think the most hottest
topic nowadays is that people tend to
use testicle as a means for diagnosis so
they're using or at least they are
looking into bio markers on the vesicles
and thereby allowing non invasive
diagnosis of the patient's an in terms
of publication if you look at this chart
that I grabbed this a few days ago that
you can see therefore if you use the
term X ISM and have into PubMed or be
used it for microvesicles
you can see that basically the
publication has jumped exponentially
from around 2008 all the way to 2014 and
I believe the publication number is
still going up quite drastically so it
is a very solid pursuit fear right now
because it basically expanded our
thinking of cell to cell communication
as Jeff mentioned earlier my previous
work is on a function mediating inter
cell communication
what that means is that the two cells
have to come in contact with one another
we want to inform yeah planning their
physical conduit to pass on the
molecules that he wants you can be cured
one other
however for vesicles there like a
wireless network we no longer need to
touch one another all they have to do is
release these vesicles which vary a lot
of message as well 13 and when once
delivered to the receiving cell is
taking illicit phenotypic changes and
those are one thing the extrasolar
vegetables are exciting as well as
expanding our horizons understanding how
cells actually completely was my mother
now jumping over further is if people
can actually study the etiology of
disease faced or at least contributed by
Edie can we actually reverse Lee employ
them or engineer them for therapy and so
the first part that people are actually
looking into is if they can use EVs and
things for immunotherapy basically by
using them as very visually speaking
they're trying to use them as a way to
exam the antigens to the immune system
such as the did Excel or natural fluids
t-cells those kind of things so that
they can elicit
meaning attribution against
disease such as cancer now for another
way that people have been trying to do
is to package our nai or other gene
therapeutic cargo into the vesicles and
then not only that many groups are
already decorating the outside of the
vesicles with targeting peripheral in
such as in this case from matthew school
they use a reduced lipoprotein [ __ ]
argued the silicone receptor neurons in
the brain and they have been doing that
personally in their paper back in 2012
actually and last but not least people
have been doing drug packaging into the
vesicles as a way to deliver there's a
few departure now people may ask me why
people choose to do vesicle so one
theory or thought is that that's a co
since they're actually produced by the
cells they were actually listed much
less genetic response in comparison to
their artificial analogs such as
lipizzans so that's why people are
actually looking into vesicle as a
therapeutic vehicle that's actually
produced endogenously by the body itself
now taking a bigger backward so we're
gonna stop a little bit are people are
trying to study vesicles but if you look
at the figured literatures a lot of them
use Kathy's diet because they had no
other means of looking at this nanometer
sized vesicles
so what they usually resort you is
something such as the tkh diets that you
can see right here those produced by
sigma-aldrich now if you look at the
vesicles actually if you look at the
instructions Sophia manufactured by
carefully you realize that they actually
do honestly report that the half-life of
these guys basically are aliphatic
chains that can insert into the
membranes they can last as long as a
hundred days for example for this peak
age 26
now the question that I propose is that
if if you actually label your vesicles
and then if you look into you either in
vitro or in vivo the question comes up
as to after a certain amount of time are
you still looking at your vesicles or
are you looking at the remnants and
remnants of the dies after the hospital
has been treated so that in something
that worried me a lot when I started
working on a trestle of vesicles and not
only that there are other dyes such as
Olympic advised such as die I those were
things that had always been our mind we
were kind of visualize them because
without seeing them there is really
parking from business that lets go
really actually work in a very dynamic
way now there are other problems such
that if you actually use the dyes to
label your vesicles the main anti
residues which you must do a lot of
washing steps in order to rid of this
not specific but not only that we do the
washing you lose a lot of your vesicles
so those are a lot of problems that
we're trying overcome now just to go
over briefly about how people actually
attack message goes for their study so
we had the conventional microscopy
techniques such as Sen Tian otherwise
atomic force microscopy and not only
that a lot of pioneers actually use X's
or more specific markers such as CD 5300
kala to GFP or in doctor a little
dispute that they actually use a so py
Hefe to label vesicles and as well
people use the inaudible techniques such
as anybody I can assess in 63 or CID one
familiar vesicles and as we not discuss
earlier people use a lot of times to see
the vesicles under the factory but the
question come to us too there may be
more than other there may be other other
protein other than CD 63 label is the
vesicles so this really opens up a lot
of questions in our mind as clear is
there a way that we can actually
effectively see the vesicles in a more
or a more broader population and then as
well as more precise labeling that gives
us a better special control resolution
so we went out to set up proper
criterias when we are designing the
experiment so first of all as as I
mentioned was to have assured really
high deliverance plasticity and also
accuracy in terms of the geospatial as
well as the temporal resolution so that
we won't be compounded by the possible
effects from the long half-life of the
guys and
resolution so since people are trying to
track these nanometer sized vesicles we
really have two veins the first one
actually to see once we put into the
animals we actually track them inside of
whole animal another one at subsoil
resolution because their nanometer size
is it possible that we can actually
track them in such a way that we can see
which organelle or how they actually
enter the recipes oh sorry in their
cells so those aren't the goals that we
set up to do now for the first part of
the talk I'll go over our earlier study
where we actually devised a way I didn't
understand how that's a kalashnikov
labelled in the body and as I described
earlier many people can use vesicle as a
therapy so you can see that most people
actually are quite familiar with
intravenous injection of any drug so
that's something that we're interested
in but we're also interesting in
information injection of the vesicles
because that will allow you to bypass
the top and very reader directly
including to the brain and some goals
for doing this study is that we are
trying to again image them in the whole
animal and not only that we would like
to do bio distribution as well as a lot
urine experience once we actually put
the vesicle in throughout the body
because these are very important
especially for rural characteristics and
we need to be fine before we consider
further of using vesicle as a vehicle a
vehicle so for this part will focus
primarily on intravenous a most recent
route so how do we achieve that
that's closer so tiny how do we were
able to effectively so we went and under
the collaboration we thought after your
buckles to use we actually use calculus
Ares which is a Marine Corp applause you
can see right here that they are very
unique from such that they have a
flashlight fluorescence sorry by a
Newman essence that's a thousand times
more sensitive than the for the pro
Firefly as well as for mineral surgeries
and then the other thing is that unlike
a salute our firefighters are freeze
Gaussian was raised does not require ATP
now this gives us a lot of advantage
over effort because we're not dependent
on a TV anymore and not only now G
because actually Feith resistant meaning
that they can actually work following
different environmental conditions
and as you can see on the bottom which
is the reaction of this substrate once
we use a substrate selectors in this
case and then when we add G and they
only require oxygen then the reaction is
great you can see on the right it's a
very high intensity light that comes out
around 400 nanometers so this really
allows us to pave a way to develop the
reporters so how do we actually target
them onto the vesica or illegal the
vesicles so what we did is right here
that nice a few model actually a tin
parts reporter system now for the top
part right here what we did right here
is that we haven't humanized the LCA
Lucifer is Julie and then we conjugated
in a transmembrane domain of the PDGF
receptor and between them we actually
have a biotin receptor protein what this
allows us to do is there once express in
the donor cells of the vesicle in this
case we tested with h TK 293 t-cells and
you can see that the transmembrane
domain right here while allowed
according to the anchor on to the plasma
membrane and then the G blue region will
be interpose on the outside now second
part of this reporter is the SSH bewray
which is the abouten ligase what this
allows to do is that once Co expressed
in the receptor of sorry Indian donor
cells you can actually have the biotin
receptor protein as indicated right here
to be by accumulated once the Spile -
Nora - who provides us a multi-modal
imaging platform because we can actually
conjugate many different imaging agent
that's not conjugated subscribe Appling
and they're doing other casually imaging
analysis and doesn't think I think I
will show a bit of a spark right here so
once we actually Express this reporters
then we'll isolate the vesicles and then
we can inject it with you
animals fight the you can't argue in
subjection then we can actually see
where they go about and this is in fact
what we saw so first of all we would
like to characterize whether we
successfully label the vesicle as well
now on the top arm
well right here as you can see we have
the GP or the membrane panel version
which is actually conjugated and then
Express on the membrane of the vesicle
incidentally this is the amino go
labeling of the gene and then not only
that we actually confirm that we
successfully isolated vesicles or Isis
arms by using CV 63 only bodies and
further we actually use anti biotin
antibodies and prove that these vesicles
can also be pollinated so by using this
multi there were three things that we
achieve is that we can actually get
beautiful to the vesicles and not only
that we have animation appearing on the
surface of the vesicles and in
comparison all control right here which
is just the freeform free-floating
formal treatment we don't see any type
of labeling by the GV we still
successfully confirmed with absolutely
63 which means we have excellent and for
the control we don't have anybody
initially meaning that the system is
actually quite specific and clean now we
would like to test further now we know
that it labels the vesicles but is the
protein still actor does it actually
steer we can use biomass as activity so
what we write here is that we isolated
vesicles so for each study light it's
verified that what we did is that we did
it we found that 300 G followed by 2,000
G rid of the solar degrees then we
filter it with a 0.32 micron filter then
was found them down with a hundred
thousand G spin to isolate our vesicles
then we subjected them to strippers
gradient and we found that the vesicle
activity for the bioluminescence
actually showed quite well from freshen
3 all the way to freshen 5 whereas for
our control majority of the reaction or
the activity for the final message is
actually an expression which signifies
the free-floating bound type of on T V
then we actually twerking pallidum and
then we tested again again the activity
Tran match is the one that we saw on the
top or the the sucrose gradient and then
for the contrary here we can see that
this trend basically fellows
use of GB protein does not bounce
anything then we did Western blot
analysis to confirm that we actually do
have again the bio cleanly going onto
the membranes which actually reflects
with the results that we saw the top
so basically freshmen three four five
six Alton as well as June protein
exposure and then we further use image
as another excellent marker confirmed
that we have a successful vesicle
isolation for our Western bar analysis
and in comparison we don't see much of
the labeling of biotin I'm very very
little amount of GV
which we suspect is just a little bit of
rebound or to that disc into the vesicle
just by rounded edge thanks know so now
we have confirmed that the past closer
we created can actually have those
bioluminescence as far as multimodal
imagery platformer so we went on to see
it is possible to actually image them in
vivo so just what we did again we
isolate the vesicles we injected them
into the animals through the intravenous
thing then right away we at different
pilot we inject them through the orbital
vein without their substrate so
interesting for by an analysis imaging
and this is what we saw by using the
Ibis for illegal immigrant system all we
saw is a half an hour after the ID
injection you can actually see right
away that the back side or the dorsal
side of the mines coming up with a lot
of signals on the left which signifies
this flame now for our control the PBS
we actually don't see much signal at all
and then when you flip them over right
away we can actually see again the
splitting coming up and also liver and
on the right right here is our X X sorry
X FIFO analysis where we actually
extract the organs homogenized them and
has their bioluminescence we basically
found similar finding that liver as well
as the spring had the most activity
whereas the control just theories the
typical background amount of file new
message that we have seen as well as
previously reported
now we previously mentioned about the
capability of what the motor image
so we want to test this by using a
forest limited tomography or FN key and
again what we did right here is that we
conjugated the vesicles that we isolated
with Alexis 887 and then afterwards we
injected into the animals through the
intravenous pain half an hour later then
we expose them to FMP imaging and as you
can see on the lap right here again
delivery as well as a spleen started to
shine up right away and then on the
right right here is basically 3d
rendering of the images that we saw that
again the liver and the screen came up
whereas the PBS control just showed the
typical background for essence that you
expect so these are not enough you
actually satisfy our desire to find
exactly where they doorbell so we
decided to actually unfortunate have to
sacrifice the minds at different time
points after interviews objection so
what we did here is at half an hour one
hour and then at three hour and all the
way up to 360 minutes we to six hours we
actually isolated the organs and then
from organize them and then tested them
for bioluminescence we detect the
position of the vesicles for the time
and what we found is actually very
striking as you can see on the top layer
here now again these animals when
sacrifice are not diffused so what we
saw is that the spring actually show up
as one of the highest organ exhibiting
the signals and this is followed by
deliberate which is a glue and the lung
which is in red right here then as well
as the kidneys on the right right here
you'll realize their scale bar is quite
different they're much much lower which
shows that again on the on the right is
the green the far in the muscles showing
you that we actually don't get much
going into the brain as expected and
this is anticipated based on fields
finding as well got as opposed to
intervene transaction isn't going to be
playing very well and we don't see very
much for the part as well as the muscles
in this case now this actually brought
another question to us is there okay we
see a lot and point to you to spleen as
well as liver but which organs are
actually actively process for me
so we decided to do another set
experiment very similar one but instead
after we sacrificed the mouse I mean I
should profuse the animals with PBS so
basically what we're trying to do here
is to rid of the blood inside the organ
so the vesicles are absolutely being
processed by these organs you expect the
signal to be somewhere between and this
is what we saw and very surprisingly the
splitting actually would show one of the
highest signal became one of the lowest
this actually suggests to us does
explaining actually does not actively
process the vesicles but rather it being
me the temporary reservoir for the
vesicles to be stored before the urban
process by the other organs and then if
you look at the kidney produce also very
interesting right here they actually
became one of the highest whereas back
on the top in the non perfuse animals
they actually show one of the lowest now
this is something that we think go over
when we go into the urine clearance
suggesting that a small percentage of
the vesicle we actually do go through
the kidneys but if we look at the liver
right here as well as long you can see
that the trend is very much similar as
the ones that we see on the top which is
here as well as here I'm going to clear
the arrows because it's getting a little
bit too crowded I basically can see that
both the liver and the long did not
change their distribution very much
before and after profusion I suggest
until I've had these two organs actually
one of them I'm great organ processing
the vesicles seeing I be administration
and again on the right you can see that
that since you've had distribution
pattern for the brain firing the muscles
are still on a very low side meaning
that not much vesicles actually just
deliver to them by the way now we want
to prove there what we saw and the
kidneys actually true so again coming
back to this slide right here remember
that the kidney used to be one of the
lowest and now that they are one of the
highest so we decide to take but profuse
to me and then did
immunofluorescence you mister chemistry
basically now on the top right here row
right here you can see we have two
because all experimental that once we
injected them with harvester vesicle sir
you have harvested the kidney and we did
a session bio sanctioning and good
immunofluorescence you can see that
where the arrow is pointing at right now
you can see magenta light colored
showing you vesicles are being located
by using the entity with antibody
whereas if we use the vesicle that's not
in labor by gtp which is our control
right here you cannot see much of the
vesicles actually going to here just to
show you that the fluorescence labeling
is really quite specific so this told us
that once the N was been confused a lot
of the magic is pushed to the kidney now
we're very perplexed as to how this
might have happened so we went on to
test the blood and urine fairies so i'll
robert the urine clearance first what we
did is that again very similar
experiment at similar time points half
an hour one hour three hour we are even
up to six hours we look at them and see
we collected the urines and trying to
see how much bioluminescence of activity
are being observed and we found that
it's very very unique that it starts at
very low half an hour right after
ingestion and it jumps up to one of the
highest peak around an hour of injection
then this is a forward bite i'd be fine
from ninety minutes and on all the way
to three hours so these suggest to us
that the vesicle even though a very very
small percentage because if you look at
the scale bar here we're talking about
around with your point zero one percent
of the initial bills i actually been
cleared through the urine
however we actually did another test
where we actually just ejected the gene
which is a feet floating hurtling the
pattern is actually drastically
different patterning is such that the
signal would be the highest on the top
and then followed by exponential decay
and all the way to the bottom over time
so this provided some indirect evidence
that the vesicles are can actually clear
through the kidney and not only that it
goes back for a while with what we
observed in the profuse kidneys such
that once you actually sacrifice the
unknown and
since they cannot pee anymore music Amy
so all the vesicles are being pushed to
the Fenian baby Nadia boobies and this
will suggest to us the reason why there
are so much vesicle signal giving bound
in the kidneys now coming back to the
blood as you can see right here on the
left we can see that the blood is
interesting they actually go through the
vesicle actually go through of bimodal
DK so first of all they will go through
a very quick decayed phase which lasts
for about 20 minutes then they will
enter a second DK phase which lasts from
around 200 minutes so this makes sense
because the fast decay in the first
place basically allows them to
distribute to the different organs that
you saw from our studies with the bio
distribution and then for the latter
part of the decay which is about if you
want to minions consider this half-life
is the part where the organs first you
process them and this actually matches
really well with what we found with the
organ studies now with these you're
really really surprised that this is how
fast as the testicles gets cleared
because previous study before ours were
suggesting that the vesicles can
actually be stuck inside on the animals
up to 24 or 48 hours by using by Mabel
its vesicles and what we found there is
that a lot of Haskell actually just
cleared basically within six hours or
slightly lighter now the next edge that
we work with has is that okay a lot more
trying to do specifically from theory
tumor as a possible that we can actually
localized or deliver desperately tumor
so this is a critical principle study so
what we did right here is that we have
the tumors in this case is just a feel
much cooler that's expressing entry so
as you can see we implant the tumors
through the chest area of the mice so
both on the left and the right chest in
three different South years or one week
and then you can see that by using ideas
imaging system you can see the tumor
formation quite well but once we inject
them with the GP vesicles you can see
that the signal actually came up through
the femur area as well for both subject
1 2 & 3
and not only that after
we actually did X Evil's organ analysis
we can see that the amount in the tumors
actually comparable to the ones in this
flame on the liver so this suggests that
the festival think that deliver to the
tumor is quite well and we're said worth
speculating that this could be due to
the leaky vasculature of the tumors
which are quite commonly seen in many
types of tumors and that's why the
vesicles can filter them by readily so
with these we prove that the vesicles
can actually be imaged with a whole
animal resolution and we actually found
that the diffusion in the face of the
vesicle is actually quite dynamic there
such that from half an hour to one hour
post injection we actually go to explain
followed by the liver and the long and
then the rest of the organs and then
from here the animation phase we
actually see one hour to six hours he
actually starts to get degraded on
processor primarily we believe theory
that he paddock but since we see a very
little amount of him coming out from the
urine and then through the kidney leave
a very small amount actually he come out
from the email pathway now and we also
showed that they actually localized the
finger has a propensity experiment so we
have just gone through the full animal
imaging maliki that we developed so the
next step is to see if we can actually
overcome the poor animal resolution it's
if we can look further and deeper into
the sub smaller compartment of the cells
so this is how we actually did it and to
be honest we do not want to leave them
below because the technique is much
there is just a not to use so one right
here is that we actually simply
conjugated common foliage and more of
the other infirmities of too far
security because we would like to do
more than one color so the first one
feel feeling we're familiar with but on
the other hand we also have
conjugated them or labeled attack them
with TD tomato so what this allows that
he was actually very interesting it's
because that the Ashley allows these
fluorescent proteins to be sorted into
the inner leaflet of the lipid bilayer
now the reason why I mentioned about
inner leaflet is quite important which
I'll mention
but at the bottom right here is
something that you'll see is that here
is again rhe 1593 key cells stabili
expressing orbit Hall again I'm not I'm
not validated GFP you can see the cells
actually are completely covered with the
GFP and you look closer you can see that
a lot of SQLite structures are being the
bees were butted either around on the
cells or around the periphery of the
cells so this is really quite exciting
so this is being imaged by lifestyle
confocal microscopy and I have to tell
you that you do live so image we
actually preserve the structure really
well and this is something that you
cannot readily achieve with fit cells so
by doing this this really allows us to
monitor how the principles are
communities and then not only that you
can actually do them through perhaps
initially you have an understanding of
their control resolution so moving on we
worked with some characterization even
though we see them being release you
know and looking like budding off from
the cells we would like to see it may
actually be able to specify well so what
we did right here is we have to sell on
this one is again 10 a 3d with some GFP
and the other one's come to be tomato
then we actually isolate the vesicle in
this study we actually isolate them by
similarly 300d followed by 2000 G but in
this case we use it's your point in
micron filter then after the filtration
we did a ham pathology spin to isolate
our vesicles then afterwards we actually
subjected them to surface gradient and
then protein powder to show that we can
actually be able to effectively and this
is something we saw also for the Western
you can see that for expression 3 to 5
we have the presence of cottage with P
which shows you that you know the upon
European vehicles a test goes quite well
and this is actually operated by the
presence of a wyx which is FX is no
marker so that's for Punk jerky hubbub
home theater middle we found exactly the
same thing of that palm tree tomato
again labels 3 4 & 5 and then in the
presence of the helix protein showing
you that on CD committal do legal
clothes as well so let's put them to the
test but before that we face a question
because we once think that this labeling
actually goes into the inner leaflet of
the vesicles so as you can see we did PE
M so this is with collaboration as well
as the PBM image we did a collaboration
with Maria Ericson from Harvard Medical
School
conventional am Center now you can see
for the left will have the vesicles they
were with and the GFP basically we're
pulling for the pathology of P and if a
seeker most of them or most of them if
you see are on the membrane and
similarly are the same for the PD tomato
now once we made our mean only problem
with NTP community body most of the
signals are on the membrane of the
vesicle now the question comes is that
this is still not specific not to tell
us that is actually in the inner leaflet
because some of them may suggest them to
be on the outside
unfortunately based on the image so we
didn't do a simple a very effective way
of deciphering whether this is on the
inner or the outer leaflet so as you can
see what we do is right here on the left
is Pompey EFT experiment on the right is
a funky Tomato Festival experiment what
we did is that we actually amino broader
the vesicles so we may know about them
on to nitrocellulose membrane and then
at different concentrations from 5000
anagram all the way to 39 anagram in a
great in fashion and then we immuno
program with entity Aviv in the presence
or the absence of the detergent
what this male also to do is that if the
protein that we're labeling with is
inside the membrane you should not be
able to label them in the absence of its
version because the surgeon actually
breaks up a membrane yet in the persons
the detergent because the membrane has
been broken out the antibody will be
able to enter into the inner leaflet of
the vesicle and they're thereby labeled
looking of interest and this is exactly
what we saw inside that all or most of
the signal from an t GP is actually
only after the addition of the detergent
and basically we found the same thing
for the comment related PD for meto
vesicles now some may ask why we care so
much about the energy flow of oil in
such that we're concerned that it may
actually affect the turbine in Modesto
if you actually continuously label the
outside or the best clothes we decided
to try the strategies such that we label
the inside and not the outside so in
this way we are trying to minimize the
effect of additional protein isn't that
on the best for membrane so next we
actually want to test if we can actually
do live cell imaging and see a better
person actually being dead exchange
between different cellular populations
because you're gonna get a lot of
previous pioneering works a lot of them
actually not intensive conventionally
but they almost make it sound like
vesicle actually are unidirectional but
we know that that's not a case back in
our mind so we like to see if this is
actually a multi-directional exchange of
the vesicles as to how the cells
actually engage by another so we did a
proof of principle studies such there we
have our 293 t-cells label with palm
Felipa mate oh and then we also have our
GBM at least like three which is
expressly found GFP and we cultured them
and did live cell imaging and what is
always interesting is that if you look
at this enlarged image right here we see
that a lot of vesicle like structures I
actually at the tip of these are
obviously like protrusions and very
presidentially a recent publication
actually shows that this may be
something with it for micro zones where
the cells as they migrate they didn't
have enough time to attack the processes
and left behind or release vesicles
during this migration process so this is
actually quite interesting there we did
not know that there's such a thing for
magazines but later on this may be
something exactly like button reported
now for the second row right here we're
trying to show that again you can see
the vesicles actually which is green
this place actually goes into the red
cells and then vice versa such
the red vesicles actually concentrate
about the green cells telling us that
the testicles actually do get
transferred multi-directional it's not
unidirectional so lately consider a
tissue
the vesicle mediated communication is
actually multi-directional and this is
actually quite dramatic in terms of our
understanding in interstellar
communications well what this is not
enough we would like to see if we can
actually in time-lapse imaging so again
this is to show you again this is some
z-stack confocal image which is a little
lifestyle where you can actually see a
lot of the vesicles so what we did right
here is that we isolated how much
validity tomatoey beam and then we
treated them onto pathology P expressing
cells 293 cells in this case you can see
a lot of the vesicles around the 33 of
the 293 Canelo's ready to dock or in the
periphery okay so what do we see if we
can actually do find you a solution like
this so businesses expect example image
right here which later I will ask our
moderator to play so but before that
allow me to show you that at this point
as well at this point you can already
see that there are red light vesicles
has been actually either attached or
involved by the receiving cells and more
interestingly if you look at this point
space right here you will see that there
may be something like a uncle's on
because that it will be a quite a big
vesicle coming out from this area so um
could you please play the movie and then
let us see what the movie was like
Thank You Don
so this is quite dramatic because if you
look at it this is been thicken for over
10 minutes and if you have found or if
you're doing high-resolution imaging you
know that usually then we get full of
bleach quite quickly but in this case I
barely have to adjust the for the laser
power so we were quite surprised I like
that that it's actually quite resistant
before the bleaching in fact we don't
exactly know the reason as to why that
is but we're speculating maybe one is
that the vesicles or the Plumber foliage
it he or he tomato are inside the
vesicle and then they actually allow
them to escape photo oxidation because
there may not be as much oxygen
available for for the region to occur
but again that's only a slight revision
regardless this shows us that this tool
is actually very effective for long-term
finalise imaging as subcellular
resolution so we decided to go on one
step further is to see if we can
actually see them in vivo so we have to
take collaborate with dr. food doctor
for Samantha from MGH and have a medical
school such that we did a model right
here as you can see what we did is gonna
meet for us on pointers so we have our
c57 black and then we have ER for
thymoma
stable we expressly average with P then
we first installed a dosa skin full
chamber which is on right here then we
actually inject these cells into the
chamber then after night days we did
multifocal inter vivo much faster in for
vital microscopy and this is something
that we'll see with these movies right
here so this movie right here will show
you what has been image right here and
it's really dramatic so don't could you
please play the next movie
you
you
you
so as you can saw a lot of vesicles are
being released by all these cells and
then this is actually inside animal life
so this is really quite dramatic then we
decided to actually look at higher
resolution so if you focus on this one
which is something that you will see in
this movie to be very serious about it
depletes the next movie please
Thank You Don so this is a sari you can
see the Baskervilles being released by
the cells inside animals this really
tells us that this is happening inside a
large animal and no longer just
imagination now the other thing is that
what happens if you look at the
extracellular space this is something
that we were very stunned as to how fast
the vesicles are being released and
traffic inside a tumour meter so Don
could you please the next movie for this
one
you
that was all very fast but you can see
that some of the basketball action
travel in clusters instead of this
single vesicles that you can see right
here right now so these are single ones
but inside the movie you can see that
some of them actually travel in clusters
in the circle that we actually depicted
inside the movie so this is really quite
amazing but I know the movie played a
little bit quite quickly but if you look
a little bit close to the time those
movies are actually for half an hour so
the fact that the reporter can actually
last such a long imaging session tells
us that his reporters actually find it
useful for a long journey the depot
study and also for you Peter Scott
explores in fact these vesicles now we
have winners come we know that they
actually released by the cells we know
there is multi-directional
you know that they actually exist in
vivo what's next do they actually
actively deliver their cargo that's
something that really like to see so a
lot of really good work have been shown
that I suppose actually three four I'm a
I'm a Monday but we really like to
visualize them so only right here is
actually we devised a two-part reporter
so what we did here is as you can see on
the Left we have our Vesper on a
reporter so as you can see we have again
I'm elated
Edie Camille so what this allows us to
do is to label our donor cells and
subsequently the vesicles is isolated
with red but at the three-time my are
untranslated region through ia PR we
actually happen with MS two binding
sites 2040 Peaks what allows us to do is
that we would have the transcripts which
in this case shown in blue like this and
then we for expressing with another
reporter so again the transcript is in
blue which is something that you can see
right here and then we have a second
part of reporter which is the RNA
reporter this we have the ms2 property
so what this property no else to do is
that it will bind to the ms2 binding
sites and then again the corporate thing
is actually counted to get be so you
have Emma's TCP the core protein G
what what happened was like this so if
you look on the right
typically the proper thing which will
recognize the ms-20 forehead if they
don't recognize it they will actually go
to a new four years because we have a
nuclear localization signal following
the GOP so that's when they don't watch
me on to the transcript but once it's
found to the transcript which is located
right here we expect them to actually be
recruited by random chance
and then by random chance they will be
released either through direct cutting
or by me through the not a place for the
body and then we will have vesicles that
first of them they'll be read but if
they do mRNA then they will be shown in
green because we have to cope hurting
balance TVs and mining and this is
actually exactly what we saw in sada in
our experimental condition we have MS to
protein GFP co-expressed with somewhat
politically the tomato with MS 24 time
so we have the cells first pressing
these we actually the vesicles and then
we look at them and we can actually see
t4 middle play well because there's for
the vesicles but not only that within
these vesicles we actually see the green
signal which signifies the presence that
anti a package we mean these vesicles in
contrast if we actually move ms 24 RNA
binding sites we actually don't see the
green signal at all this basically throw
is that the mRNA you get packaged even a
membrane we when we do see them on the
vesicles then the next question is okay
we can visualize transcripts but do they
actually Cleary
a row can they actually be translated
and thus and the question that we decide
to challenge so what we did is to
actually understand how fast during the
mRNA in delivered by the plastic voice
gets translated once they actually in DC
by the be seeking cells so what we did
right here is actually multiplex in
reporters that we have actually gone
over in the past few slides so what we
did right here again is actually by
using common for a rigid because
which you can see on the left so what
this allows us to do is we'll label our
donor cells as well as our UC plus rate
as well as well as our ethical is green
then we actually use G mu P which is
something that we discussed earlier what
we're really interested in here is
actually its transcript so again
remember that G will be as extremely
sensitive so we would have our product
of the vesicle we will have green
vesicle which GP printing on demand on
the membrane outside but we would also
have the transcript of the GV within yet
then we took these vesicles and then we
treated them onto our recipients cell
which is like 36 GBM simply expressing
entry so when this happens once we treat
it onto them you can actually see that
the green vesicles BK cannot apply the
red cells so this will also do a few
things so one thing is that we can
actually see the best philosophy by flow
cytometry analysis by facts analysis
such that if you have a swab the EOD
type of the green and the red signal but
if you only have the cells alone you
only have the red way in addition to
that we can actually do vesicle and
Montenegrins lesion essay that you can
see on the right so basically over time
if we actually starts to see an increase
in the bynum Messer's that will signify
that the mRNA are being ethically
translated by the recipient cells and
this is actually how the experiment
schedule works so what we did is we cap
the vesicles and then we actually
treated them by using something similar
to confession essentially we centrifuge
that that's the vesicles onto the
recipient cells at 40 degrees Celsius so
what this allows to do is that the
vesicles will dock onto the cells will
now be internalized because they are at
4 degrees Celsius
then after dead after an hour in half
resume the temperature the temperature
to 37 degrees Celsius and then we
replace a media to rid of any excess
vesicles that and that has now been
bound and then we have
Media supplemented with or without
cyclohexane wine which is second hexa-
translation inhibitor and then we
started collecting the samples at
different times from zero hour all the
way to 24 hours and then throughout all
these time points we sa4 again something
regression two things one is the best
for update and the second thing is the
classical mRNA deviation and this is
what we saw so again on the Left right
here is a reminder of how our sticker
looks and on the right top right right
here we can see best people do get up
the high regularly so again this is
minus 1.5 hour when the screen fashion
is be gone so there is no respite or
object at all or donkey but after one
half hour of infection where you can see
the vesicles organ thought or about five
to ten percent of the cells have the
vesicles talked on the membrane and you
start to see the signal going up
see you around three hour or oh by a big
farm-to-table hour and a platform
between 12 to 24 hours what happens with
what kind of translation then is that
it's remarkable that if you look at the
transition pattern now sorry something I
forgot to mention is the red line is the
one without cycle handsome white and the
blue line is the one cycle I survived
and then we look at the bottom led RNA
translation you can see that soon after
your vesicle docking or update within
one hour which is the red line right
here wait that cycloheximide
the bioluminescent signal is already
going off and this goes all the way up
to 12 hour followed by a plateau from 12
hour to 24 hour which coincides
was the update pattern that we see right
here on the top and then in contrast if
we actually add the translational
inhibitor then we actually see this
translation you can suppress
throughout the period of this experiment
so this tells us that the vesicle
deliver RNA translated quite readily
especially within an hour after its
update and not only that we took one
step further we did need some protein
synthesis I say to ensure that our
cyclohexanol
even these successfully suppressed as
regional event as you can see right here
once we add second high sunlight which
is shown in blue that transition level
basically is down to the very bottom and
then in without second heights of money
you can still see a background level of
translational going on and this is shown
by liquid HPP vapour which is something
very similar to during your life as well
family very quickly but this one is a
little safer where you don't need to
play with the radioactive materials so
with these we actually sure want to stop
the vesicle transfer as well as Eska
mediated communication very dynamic and
multi-dimensional and the next step that
we're interested in doing is to see how
tumor vesicles are distributed inside
the animal by using the reporter
techniques that you develop so first of
all like you identified the testicle
receiving cells from the Traverse and
mean and then we will actually do them
by total betrayal and it's like people
and not only that as you have seen we
can use both the fluorescence as well as
a by Onesimus methods to allow us to do
second-level ascendant competition where
we don't have to be my aunt at least
such as NPA in homicide or other
researchers at the key manner and not
only that we like to try to use this
vesicles for imaging as well as for gene
therapy where you saw the imaging but
the next step that we like to take is to
actually even for therapy and it's
really important as most of you know
that most of the vesicle or at least in
the nipples and field they actually do
get recruited by task clear and there
was a mole as limited edition so we're
very interested in tracking and seeing
how in fact that the vesicles are
delivered to their receive in cells and
whether we can actually escape the
degradation pathways just to mention
something about a collaboration that
also ongoing by using this technique is
and we actively collaborating with dr.
Chandra start that we're developing
microfluidic chips to capture TV and
vesicles and this is a very exciting
project that were able to see
publication this year and then what
allows us to do basically is that just
by using the patient's blood or serum we
can actually wanna clear a microfluidic
chip
capture the vesicles that's specific to
the GPS and then we can do the
downstream analysis very dirty qpcr or
next-gen sequencing and thereby a lot to
see analysis to see a pattern of GBM
patient specific signature and last but
not least already thank a lot of my
colleagues from Boston or this basically
dr. saundra previous lab is conceived as
my mentor in the center and also on my
right right here would be dr. Ibaka tell
us they have been very very helpful and
they're discrete members and we meet
have been much worse out of the team
this is not released in McGuire which
are also very supportive in the early
parts of the study and this is just
acknowledgement slice you show please
well yeah that many many people to think
that we have a very good clean back in
Boston from the doctor center field lab
as well as from dr. cannerts Tanner's
lab and also the in vivo imaging that
you saw a very elegant study but you
thought it was some man poster and as
well as the really really really
beautiful here images with myriad sand
from hims conventional Ian core and also
we collaborate very closely with dr. al
vice-leader Chinese law as I mentioned
earlier and Jason McGuire dr. johannes
lähde from exited our hostel on these
studies and last but not least would
like to thank all of our funding
sponsors from NIH as well as my
fellowship during my period here's
postdoctoral fellow years from a
Canadian Institute of Health Research so
with that one just like to promote our
school in national university we have a
very strong team of biomedical engineers
their work on a variety of fields such
as biomaterials biosensors drug delivery
molecular imaging and even some power
and nanosystems so as you can see right
here this is the one created by one of
our professor that they can actually
test here in a lot of the biomarkers
they can actually cut just by using a
test
which is something before and we were
also developing some fiber please nano
generator is where you can actually
generate electricity to space engineer
so we're a very dynamic group that we
highly encourage people to check it out
if you're interested and here are the
keywords if you type in mph you BME you
can find us and someone else will put on
for length by three beats and for the
movies if you like to look at them more
specifically I didn't have also been
published so don juan's have have two
links to them that you can put it up and
I don't like to thank you for your
attention and if there's any questions
that great thanks for that highly
informative presentation dr. Lai before
we get started on the
question-and-answer session I would
again like to remind our audience that
you can submit questions by typing them
in the Q&A box you'll find that at the
lower left of the presentation window
we've already had several good questions
come in from our audience so let's go
ahead and get started our first question
is have you ever tested labeled exosomes
from different donors like Mouse derived
cell lines do you expect that they would
have different target organs that's a
very good question actually
so we have not tested direct comparison
between the different source of the
exercise so basically short answer for
that would be no we have not tested them
but we do expect them to carry different
tropism basically because what you're
asking so we can anticipate that the
other than focusing but we do not test
it so there's something that could be
tested over in your interesting Realty
collaboration for that great thanks for
that answer our second question is have
you determined the average size of the
EBS before injection in mice thank you
so for this one we did use the nano side
system to test so since we actually
sorry I mention a little bit quickly we
did filter them through a point to 2
micron footbath study so the average
size we saw then somewhere around if I
remember correctly sorry it is inside
our application that we do have an
otherside size distribution it is
somewhere around 150 range so we did
these four than the average size for the
vesicles prior to the injection into the
mice and something interesting is that
we do actually anticipate so this
relates back to the earlier question not
only do the different donor vesicle my
effective focusing but the size may
actually affect is provision because
this is what exactly they saw in the
limb person field so that would be
something interesting to test so again
we'll be happy to work with the other
interesting thank you great thank you
for that a next question coming in is
whether or not you check the health of
the cells producing the fluorescent
vesicles
hi that's a good question so protect
yourself the health of a cell for the
person festival we do know that they
only grow slower then one of their
counterparts the basic reader control
now that's expected because you're
putting on reporters on video membranes
so we do know that especially when
there's some over-expansion system even
though it is a stable expression system
we definitely did see a slower growth
how healthy are they in our case did we
actually generate stable lines so we
actually can repeatedly use them without
having to you know expect again and
again and by using stable infection was
actually allowing us to avoid the
possible artifact from accidental
transferring of the plasmas so by doing
this again the health is definitely not
as healthy as the non inspector or
non-league we expressed ourselves but
then again all of the models that we're
testing right here I actually test
ourselves so it's kind of hard to define
what is healthy considering that they
are really not normal so yes it does
carry a burden on them but I think
that's expected with every type of
reporter system thank you perfect thank
you for that one last question is what
why why do you prefer to use sintra
Gatien as opposed to other methods for
evey isolation
that's actually a very good question lie
the short answer for that is that it is
something that we're most accustomed to
at that time now we know that there are
a lot of other that needs something else
you know such as you know people a lot
of people probably know EXO freak as one
even though we don't know that it might
not be as clean other people using you
know beats those are the things that
came out before our hike basically so we
now know that they exist but when we're
developing those tools we didn't before
at least we're not as familiar with
there's also so that's what we're going
to try but I think that's that point
something that we can try and compare
because again with the tools that we
develop I can will be interesting to see
if they actually effects again the yield
as well as the distribution of the size
of the best filter you isolate so I
think that's something very interesting
for a very good question yes something
that we're always wondering when we
moral quote stuff like only one method
of isolation thank you for that
unfortunately we're out of time today I
want to thank the audience for their
interesting questions and participation
in today's event I would also like to
thank our sponsor Beckman Coulter and of
course dr. Charles live for making
today's webinar possible which will also
be available for on-demand viewing
through Becklund culture calm thanks
again goodbye